do you have a pesky bloodthirsty ghost
on your hands you know who to call
no no no a group of inexperienced teens
of course everybody's gonna die yes
Netflix has released Lockwood and Co a
television series where teens take on
ghosts now if only they could get to the
bottom of who's ghosting me on Tinder in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into the series some of its biggest
unanswered questions and where it could
take us in season two so make sure to
like And subscribe because I may not
always cover the shows you're watching
but when I do it's amazing meet Lucy
Carlisle a runaway hoping to make it big
in London as a ghost hunting agent you
got that right ghost hunting in the
world of Lockwood and Co a mysterious
event known simply as the problem
occurred sometime in the 1980s altering
the history of Earth as we know it this
problem refers to the emergence of
ghosts which have somehow made their way
into our world now there are a few
important things to know about these
ghosts one they only appear at night
hence why London has a daily curfew two
they can only be seen by young people
who have what is called Talent the
ability to see hear or sense the dead
and three ghosts are split into three
types type 1 the most common and weakest
like Shades or lurkers this type is
usually unaware of the living type 2
possess a limited intelligence are more
dangerous and may even want to harm the
living and by far the rarest is type 3.
only two type threes are known to ever
have existed these are actual sentient
beings and Only the strongest people
with Talent have the ability to
communicate with them one such person is
Lucy at the start of the Season Lucy has
run away from home and joined Lockwood
and Co basically the only agency that
would take her in considering she lied
on her resume and hadn't completed all
of her training there she hones her
skills and gets herself involved in a
harrowing Adventure involving ghosts
gangsters and murder and by the end of
the season Lockwood and Co are on to
their biggest case yet the missing bone
glass mirror A Relic that may answer how
these ghosts came to be and offer them a
Glimpse at the Eternal it's never
explicitly said what the Eternal is but
my guess it has something to do with the
afterlife now this bone glass is
exceptionally dangerous it was made with
the bones of seven tormented Spirits we
learn in episode 6 that not everyone who
dies turns into a ghost if you kill
someone that body isn't necessarily
going to become a source unless you make
sure of it a source is an object or
place in which a ghost enters the world
and only when someone living goes
through intense trauma do their bodies
get attached to these sources in episode
1 we learn of a ghost named Annabelle
Ward a woman who was brutally murdered
her Source became a ring the bone glass
is a source as well but as we'll find
out later it's seven sources in one
making it extra dangerous in episode 7
Lucy and her ghost fighting partner
Anthony Lockwood managed to steal the
bone glass mirror from a secret auction
and throw it into the river where it
would be picked up by fellow Lockwood
and co-member George Kareem unbeknownst
to Lucy and Anthony George has developed
a friendship with Pamela Joplin who
wants to use the bone mirror in the
hopes of finding out how the problem
started or at least that's what she
tells George with Anthony and Lucy
seemingly falling for each other over
the course of the Season George has felt
more and more on the outs and this
combined with this thirst for knowledge
Spurs him to go with Pamela and uncover
the bone glasses Secrets meanwhile
Anthony and Lucy Read The confessions of
Mary dulack a book they stole from the
black Library within the fits archives
Marissa Fitz was considered the
strongest Talent ever to live and the
only one up until Lucy to have conversed
with a Type 3 ghost her company the fits
agency is England's largest ghost
hunting agency and possesses several
relics in ancient tomes the confessions
of Mary du Lac are important because it
tells the story of the bone glass mirror
and a man by the name of Edmund
Bickerstaff an occultist who used
witchcraft to experiment on the dead and
create the bone glass itself remember
how I said the bone glass was seven
sources in one Edmund Bickerstaff
tortured seven of his patients and used
their bones and Spirits to craft this
occult object in the illustration found
in Mary dulack's book Anthony and Lucy
find this spiral formation on it one
which George had been drawing all over
the kitchen table in episode 4 while
uncovering the bone glass George briefly
gazed into its spiral making him
increasingly obsessed with it Anthony
and Lucy now know George is in danger
with the help of skull a Type 3 ghost
held in this jar and former servant of
Edmund Bickerstaff Anthony and Lucy find
out that this Looking Glass isn't a
mirror rather a window and that all who
look into it are killed thus the two
head back to Edmund bickerstaff's Crypt
in the hopes they can stop George and
Pamela from whatever it is they have
planned in the Crypt George finds quill
Kips fighting off a ghost quill is a
member of the Fitz agency a rival to
Lockwood and Co and he's is considered
the best agent in the country but his
fighting here would say otherwise George
has to save him and we find out quill is
losing his talent this happens to all
you says they get older they lose the
ability to see ghosts and Pamela quickly
holds quill at knife Point coughing him
and George is like who were these cuffs
for Pamela's original plan was to tie
George up and have him look into the
mirror she knew something Edmund
Bickerstaff didn't when he attempted to
use the bone glass over a hundred years
ago he needed a youth with the ability
to see the dead not someone who was
older with quill now tied up she no
longer needs George but she doesn't know
that quill has lost his ability so this
makes for a very interesting situation
meanwhile Anthony teams up with other
members of Quill's team to fight off
Julius winkmann a crazed Relic Hunter
who's looking to get back that bone
glass they stole from him Lucy heads off
into the Crips to save George now George
tells Pamela that Quill's abilities have
left him which puts him him on the
chopping block to witness what happens
when you look into the mirror Pamela's
goal here is to have the one who looks
into the mirror describe what he or she
sees but before she can go through with
it Lucy appears and offers to save
George she's a far more powerful Talent
with the ability to see type threes if
there's anyone who's going to look into
that mirror it should be her but as
Pamela unveils the mirror Lucy looks
away instead holding up the jar filled
with skull's head as he looks into the
mirror he tells them those seven spirits
haven't made it to the Eternal but are
rather trapped the bone glass should be
destroyed George seeing that Lucy's in
danger Rams the glass and it starts to
break with Pamela drawn to its glow she
looks into it and exclaims it's
beautiful before disintegrating we see
these seven spirits Escape From The Bone
glass and head upward having finally
been set free but that's not the last of
their worries the blast blew apart the
chains covering the body of Edmund
Bickerstaff Pamela brought his corpse
down here so he could bear witness to
her Discovery normally iron chains are
enough to contain the spirit within but
the blast seems to have blown them off
allowing his Spirit to attack luckily
Anthony comes to save the day after he
was just shot by a mysterious figure
known as the golden blade not much is
known about him as his character doesn't
appear in the novels but some have
speculated he could be Rupert Gail a
master swordsman working with none other
than Penelope Fitz Penelope Fitz is the
head of the fits agency and
granddaughter of the greatest ghost
hunter ever Marissa and we do see the
two conspiring throughout the season as
well as at the end of the episode with
the bone glass destroyed in
bickerstaff's spirit contained Lucy
Anthony George and quill emerge tired
but Victorious the bone glass shards
will go to the furnaces and Julius
winkmann off to prison this also puts
into question Quill's future he and
Anthony made a bet that whichever team
didn't solve the case would have to
disband but Anthony tells him not to
worry about it since quill has lost his
ability it's unclear what role he'll
play in future Seasons Anthony lies to
inspector Barn stating that he didn't
get a good look at the man who shot him
likely to hide the fact a Lockwood and
Co will be searching for this guy behind
deepak's back Deepak is short for the
Department for psychical research and
control as Anthony suggests the golden
blade is part of something much bigger
and this seems to be where season 2 is
headed the golden blade also knows about
the death of Anthony's parents perhaps
he was even involved in that not much is
known about Anthony's parents however
there are a few Clues sprinkled
throughout the season Anthony was
orphaned at the age of six after his
parents passed away we don't know how
they died but the Golden Blades suggests
something nefarious was at play their
home passed on to Anthony and is the
only thing he has left of them this
place is all that's left of my parents
his past is extremely painful he keeps
whatever reminded of it behind the
locked door in his home all I can say is
that I really enjoy talking about my
past
and that's what's behind that door the
season ends with a cliffhanger with
Anthony promising not to keep any more
secrets and revealing to Lucy and George
what's behind that secret locked door so
what could be behind there we know it
has something to do with his past and is
very painful so my best guess is that it
has something to do with his parents
maybe even the ghosts of his parents
remember that not everyone who dies
becomes a ghost they have to die in a
truly traumatic fashion and it's very
likely Mr and Mrs Lockwood died in a
sudden and traumatic way what if Anthony
has kept their sources which bind their
ghosts locked away in this room last but
not least is the fate of skull who he
last Saw being forced to look into the
bone glass it seems as though he
survived but Lucy says he hasn't said
anything since expect him to make a full
recovery in season 2 as a verifiable
Type 3 is a valuable member to have as
part of the team that's it for this
video what did you think of Lockwood and
Co and more importantly what do you
think is behind that door I want to hear
your thoughts in the comments below be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thingsstory YT until
next time remember